brouillard et vitesse à l'origine d'un
carambolage monstre sur l'autoroute près
de thionville en moselle une centaine de
voitures sont en cause le bilan 53
blessés dans huit dans un état grave
après le meurtre d'un jeune homme à hier
à evry et les experts de la violence
urbaine s'interroge sur l'évolution
inquiétant de ce phénomène en france
sommes-nous en passe de ressembler à
l'amérique journée nationale de
l'audition 7 millions de français
entendent mal sont toujours s'en rendre
compte et trop souvent lorsqu'ils
consultent il est déjà trop tard
mes baskets tous les jeunes français
veulent remporter ce n'est plus une mode
c'est devenu un véritable phénomène
économique les fabricants font assaut de
techniques d'originalité c'est notre
enquête de ce soir le prêt-à-porter de
l'hiver prochain défilent en ce moment à
paris du plus spectaculaire john
galliano plus abouti l'éternel yves
[ __ ] madame monsieur bonsoir
brouillard vitesse excessive chaussée
glissante tous les ingrédients étaient
malheureusement réuni ce matin sur
l'autoroute a31 au sud de thionville en
moselle pour un carambolage monstre une
centaine de voitures et de camions sont
en cause le bilan 53 blessés dont huit
dans un état sérieux une centaine de
sapeurs pompiers médecins gendarmes ont
dû procéder toute la matinée à des
désincarcérations de blessés coincés
dans leurs véhicules et un véritable
hôpital de campagne a été dressée sur
place match
nous ne sommes pas dans une casse mais
sur l'autoroute a31 chaussée couverte de
givre épais brouillard et vitesse
excessive ont eu raison de ses voitures
il est 7 heures du matin entre metz et
thionville forte circulation quand une
voiture se met en travers
je suis monté sur les c'était tellement
vite
les trois quatre voitures étaient
alignés devant en travers donc moi j'ai
réussi à freiner un peu mais après ça
qu'on s'est tapé vers l'arrière darbon
capital - 8
on entend du goût et cetera et cetera au
total une centaine de véhicules
s'entrechoquent pour ne plus former
qu'un amas de ferraille
pompiers gendarmes se mobilisent un
poste médical avancé s'installe pour
répartir des blessés au visage blême
aucun mort une soixantaine de blessés le
pronostic reste réservé pour deux
d'entre eux c'est un miracle compte tenu
surtout du fait que york il ya une heure
veut on nous ressort se transformer
l'autoroute coupée pendant cinq heures
n'a été rouverte qu'en début d'après
midi
d'après les témoins à 10 me
n'était que de 50 mètres un brouillard
qui aurait dû amener certains
conducteurs à réduire leur vitesse
au lendemain du meurtre d'un jeune homme
à evry dans l'essonne au cours d'une
bagarre entre deux bandes rivales tous
les intéressés habitants du quartier
éducateurs responsables d'associations
de jeunes ou élus ou encore des
policiers essaient de comprendre ce qui
a pu se passer
n'étant pas avec quelques années de
retard face à l'émergence de banques
prêtes à tout comme il en existe
malheureusement aux états unis ce qui
fait penser bien entendu c'est la
présence d'armes à feu le ca d'ultimes
de la violence reportage arnaud boutet
raymond chabot sur leur poitrine
la photo de sinan dans leurs yeux toute
la tristesse de sa famille ses voisins
instant de recueillement dans un profond
silence pour la communauté turque d'evry
avant le grand rassemblement à
l'extérieur
la photo du jeune homme abattu d'un coup
de fusil s'affiche partout sur les
coeurs et sur les fleurs alors que
devant les cinémas du centre commercial
l'espace ne peut contenir la foule c'est
ici qu'il est tombé
les habitants de la cité des tarterets
viennent lui rendre hommage
tu restera dans ma mémoire même s'il ya
eu des malentendus écrit cette jeune
fille des messages personnels et
touchant je garde de lui à sauver de
souvenirs d'un regard lumineux claire
vivant et d'un beau sourire un
recueillement et rejet de la violence
est là le discours devient un
mobilisateur pour rien mais il est mort
pour rien tout le monde s'accorde à dire
que s'ils n'appartenaient pas à ces
bandes rivales entre cités mais il a été
tué par un autre jeune et se pose le
problème de la circulation des armes 97
plus de 150 agression à main armée sur
le département de l'essonne
les deux premiers mois de l'année
janvier février plus de 50 agression à
main armée et quand je parle d'amour
mais jeudi par match 11
donc il existe une véritable économie
parallèle une profil bas en allemagne et
ça nous inquiète on ne s'était pas
aujourd'hui ça aurait été un mois plus
tard mais si c'était pas du côté des des
tarterets qui est une victime ça aurait
été des pyramides si ça devait arriver
ça devait arriver
il ya trop d'armes il ya trop de
violence il ya trop de circulation de
fusil qui tourne le marché de l'armée
après deux montées les habitants d'évry
n'espère qu'une chose que sa mort ne
sera pas venger qu'elle puisse faire
taire les armes
la violence urbaine est donc en train
d'évoluer dans un très mauvais sens même
s'il faut se garder de trop généralisée
dans ce domaine en effet sur le terrain
magistrat experts constatent une
radicalisation de la violence même si la
france ne connaît pas encore la
situation extrême des états unis mais
ces mêmes experts ne cachent pas leur
inquiétude pour l'avenir frédéric dupuy
le valais rire le drame d'evry un
règlement de comptes entre jeunes de
cités voisines sans être apparemment
cette fois un affrontement entre bandes
rivales mène de violences entre jeunes
de différents quartiers
soit ils s'affrontent sur des coques
boehner soit ils s'affrontent sur des
dettes de drogue soit ils s'affrontent
sur des prises de territoire mais je
crois pas qu'on puisse parler de
phénomène de bande le phénomène de bande
ou plutôt d'action collective existe
pourtant ici comme ailleurs un constat
fait par la justice ou par la police
mais aussi par les universitaires sans
être alarmistes françois houle travaille
depuis longtemps sur les violences
urbaines en france comme aux états unis
n'est pas très optimiste à partir du
moment où on commence à sortir des armes
à feu une fois il est clair qu'en face
eh bien on aura tendance à à s'en servir
aussi parce que il y as phénomène de
vengeance qui va se créer
et ce phénomène de vengeance va être bon
le connaît c'est pas la peine de rentrer
dans des descriptions c'est une escalade
classy également universitaire nicole le
guennec est aujourd'hui chargé de
mission par jean pierre chevènement les
banlieues et les arpentent depuis 20 ans
maintenant on pense que l'école ne sert
à rien qu'il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas
de sorties positives que les la police
les jeunes enfants eje insiste que la
justice et l'injustice dont ils n'ont
plus de confiance le pacte de confiance
et progrès est cassé et il faut rétablir
absolument de ces régulations renouer
coûte que coûte le dialogue entre les
jeunes des cités et les institutions
c'est aussi l'enjeu de sa mission
d'étude trouver le difficile équilibre
entre le social et le sécuritaire à
pavie près de rouen c'était aujourd'hui
une journée de recueillement à
l'occasion des obsèques de la
commerçante de 60 ans a battu mercredi
dernier par un groupe de trois jeunes la
ville portait le deuil tous les
commerces étaient fermés reportage
vincent guyenne alain duban
un art ils ont fermé boutique en ce
début d'après midi à leur manière les
commerçants de pavie ont témoigné leur
sympathie à la famille de l'épicière
ensemble et en silence ils ont rejoint
les autres habitants aux obsèques de
madame aussi beaucoup ont dû rester
dehors
l'église n'était pas assez grande si tu
reconnais c'est une femme superbe très
courageuse très gentil à 60 ans la
retraite d'espagne comme après un
vibrant hommage à l'épicière et à sa
famille
le prêtre a exhorté ses paroissiens à
contenir leur colère
ula un pardon auquel la famille ne peut
se résoudre pour l'instant ce sont trois
jeunes adolescents qui sont impliqués
dans ce meurtre
trois jeunes qui pour nous la famille
n'ont aucune circonstance atténuante
trois jeunes dont les parents sont à nos
yeux aussi responsable à pavie la
blessure reste douloureuse le travail de
deuil prendra du temps
roland dumas a été opéré aujourd'hui à
bordeaux opération de la hanche qui
était prévu de longue date le président
du conseil constitutionnel qui depuis
hier soir n'est plus seul sur le devant
de la scène dans la sphère des
pots-de-vin versés à l'occasion d'une
vente de matériels militaires à taiwan
en 1992 en effet l'ancien pdg d'elf loïk
le floch prigent a été mis nouvelle fois
en examen bien qu'il ait déclaré ne pas
être au courant d'une quelconque
transactions financières liées caroff et
christopher
mise en examen pour abus de biens
sociaux loïk le floch prigent l'ex pdg
d'elf a passé 6 hier dans le bureau des
juges au lit et wisniewski une longue
audition pour déterminer qui dans son
ancienne entreprise a décidé de verser
près de 60 millions de francs à
christine deviers-joncour une amie de
roland dumas a confié qu'il n'était pas
au courant de la présence les jours
la deuxième chose c'est que heu
et évidemment il n'était pas au courant
des fameuses commissions de 50 millions
une commission que christine
deviers-joncour dit avoir perçu pour
convaincre son ami ministre d'autoriser
une vente de frégates à taïwan
la mission est échoué mais quelqu'un
chez elf aurait quand même versé
l'argent
il s'agirait d' alfred sirventes l'homme
n'était pas seulement le bras droit du
patron d'elf
c'était aussi un ami de longue date de
roland dumas il aurait monté l'opération
à l'insu de loïk le floch prigent celui
sienne mais pourtant que son
autorisation était indispensable pour ce
type de versements mais sur le document
qu'il signe est il n'y avait jamais de
non seulement des numéros de comptes
écrit au crayon à papier une liste
confidentielle qu'il aurait présenté une
fois par an à jean louis bianco
le secrétaire général de l'elysée puis à
partir de 1991 à françois mitterrand en
personne ce soir jean louis bianco
affirme n'avoir jamais eu à connaître ni
à autoriser de telles commissions
affirmation démentie vous les avez
entendus il n'empêche qu'il est
désormais de notoriété publique que les
grands contrats donne lieu à des
commissions occultes mais officiel c'est
toute l'ambiguïté filet visseyrias
pascal pays quand on part à l'attack
d'un marché à l'étranger
il faut avoir une arme secrète la
commission lorsque la concurrence est
rude et que les sommes se chiffrant en
milliards de francs
on a souvent besoin de recruter un homme
de l'ombre qui sache convaincre les
autorités locales
c'est du moins ce qu'affirme pierre chic
et ancien administrateur de giat
industries le géant français de
l'armement terrestre
chaque entreprise quand elle va à
l'exportation que s'agit d'armements
qu'il s'agit d'être publiques centrales
nucléaires etc ou tgv est obligé
de pratiquer comme ça et suivant qu'elle
connaît plus ou moins pays elle a au
moins besoin d'intermédiaires les sommes
que le fabricant va verser à cet
intermédiaire peuvent représenter plus
de 10% du contrat total mais une partie
de cet argent prend un autre chemin
il est reversé soit par l'intermédiaire
soit par le fabricant à des tiers c'est
ce qu'on appelle le retour de
commissions en clair de la corruption
les commissions qui sont versés
normalement les agences et dans le
processus
vous êtes par les oeuvres dans certains
cas revenir en partie sur telle ou telle
personne du pays d'origine ça peut être
un parti politique ça va être une
personne pour mettre fin à cette dérive
l'oscd l'organisation de coopération et
de développement économiques a pris des
mesures pour pénaliser plus durement les
tentatives de corruption lors de marchés
internationaux au procès de maurice
papon à bordeaux c'était aujourd'hui la
plaidoirie d'arno klarsfeld un des
avocats de la partie civile qui s'est
vraiment fait connaître tout au long de
ce procès c'est les vins ont d'ailleurs
révélé deux jeunes avocats qui sont sans
doute de futurs ténor du barreau
arno klarsfeld donc et du côté de la
défense francis vul main aux côtés de m
var où ils ont tous les deux une
trentaine d'années et la fougue de leur
jeune âge au portage françois privat
philippe dumas des allures de play-boy
un homme plutôt discret arno klarsfeld
signe des autographes
francisville main ne quitte jamais son
téléphone portable
villemain 29 ans un jeune avocat sérieux
klarsfeld de 31 ans l'enfant terrible de
styles diamétralement opposées même à
donner cette image d'électron libre fait
rire même souvent assez surprenant dans
une cour d'assises 7 c'est son état
d'esprit ce n'est pas le mien
cela étant en dehors du procès j'ai une
vie c'est de vivre
j'espère être moins sérieux papon
arrivant au procès avec limousine et
gardes du corps tout ça aux frais du
contribuable français ça ça ne choque
personne de mes rollers dont du pays et
les remous les roulements à billes et
les chaussons et bien ça ça chaque bon
je viens
chacun son maître francis villemin jean
marc barr où il ya eu l'un des plus
grands d'avocats j'aurais tendance à
dire le plus grand cette fin du xxème
siècle j'essaie de m'inspirer d'hui
j'aimerais avoir le dixième de son
talent et je parle je serais déjà fait
des dégâts si j'avais le dixième de son
talent derrière arnaud klarsfeld son
père serge
c'est quand même lui qui s'exprime par
ma voix parce que ce que je pense
j'ai étudié ses nuits d'une série culte
et donc même s'il n'écrit pas ma
plaidoirie derrière le dos c'est quand
même lui qui décrit en grande partie
francisville main et une mitraillette
offerte par israël à maurice papon
une information démentie par le canard
enchaîné après la mise en liberté de
l'accusé arno klarsfeld claque la porte
du procès pour mieux revenir trois jours
après le même place fel de quatre mois
plus tard révèle un lien de parenté
entre le président de la cour d'assises
et une famille de partie civile
enfin un point commun entre les deux
jeunes avocats c'est dans leur chambre
d'hôtel respectives qu'ils ont choisi
d'écrire ou de dicter leurs plaidoiries
ce n'est pas accabler que maurice papon
est entré en prison
je souhaite qu'ils se condamner à une
peine exemplaire le pas réduite et c'est
un procès qui va servir en effet de
leçons parce que ce sont ceux des grands
exemples combative nation il a comparu
libre il a pu s'expliquer il a été
entendu
l'équité du procès a été rétablie par
cette mise en liberté
on est à l'étranger maintenant la
confiance en nos positions dans ce
procès papon en six films high arno
klarsfeld se prépare un nouveau face à
face et c'est donc m arno klarsfeld qui
plaidait cet après midi et qui n'a pas
réclamé la peine la plus lourde pour
maurice papon qui selon lui ne porte pas
le même degré de responsabilité qu'un
paul touvier aucun klaus barbie
dominique verdeilhan oui arno klarsfeld
a déclenché un nouveau mini séisme cet
après midi à bordeaux au bout de deux
heures d'une plaidoirie lui d'un ton
quelque peu monocorde et bien
l'auditoire a tendu l'oreille lorsque
arno klarsfeld a déclaré je cite demandé
la perpétuité ne serait pas acceptable
contrairement à barbie et à tous vielles
maurice papon ne voulait pas la mort de
ses victimes
alors cette échelle des peines cette
hiérarchisation du crime contre
l'humanité cette atténuation de la
responsabilité c'est depuis longtemps le
cheval de bataille de arnaud et serge
klarsfeld mais c'est pas bis cours qui
choque qui ne plaît pas chaud pour
toutes les victimes deux d'entre elles
d'ailleurs ont quitté la salle au moment
à la fin de la plaidoirie d'arno
klarsfeld et maurice david mathis ion
qui fut le premier à porter plainte en
80 nous disait bien pour moi celui qui a
mis le nom ma soeur sur une liste est
autant coupables que des officiers nazis
dans les camps de la mort alors il reste
ce soir une incertitude
quels bénéfices maurice papon tirera de
cette division affichée des parties
civiles la grève des sapeurs-pompiers de
roissy et d'orly a sérieusement perturbé
le trafic des deux aéroports parisiens
aujourd'hui à roissy par exemple 70 vols
de la compagnie air france ont été
annulés sur 235 au départ les sapeurs
pompiers des aéroports réclament un
statut particulier négociation est
actuellement en cours mais tout de même
rené vos précautions si vous devez
partir demain dans l'île de la réunion
le volcan du piton de la fournaise est
en éruption depuis plus de 24 heures
maintenant sans danger pour la
population qui vient regarder le volcan
la lave s'écoule vers la mer le
phénomène peut durer encore quelques
jours benoît moussa par milliers ils
sont montés hier soir sur les pentes du
volcan pour assister au spectacle
ils étaient si nombreux qu un dispositif
de régulation de la circulation a été
mise en place afin d'éviter les
embouteillages
un phénomène peu spectaculaire que
dangereux puisque aucune habitation
n'est menacée
l'éruption n'a pour l'instant fait qu'un
seul blessé
un baigneur imprudent ébouillanté en
plongeant dans la mer à l'endroit où se
jette la la depuis ce matin la lave
commencent à se solidifier à quelques
kilomètres du littoral
mais il est pour l'instant trop tôt pour
se prononcer sur la durée d'une éruption
car d'autres fissures peuvent apparaître
d'un moment à l'eau en attendant le
piton de la fournaise fait le bonheur
des petits malins des tee-shirts à son
effigie sont imprimées et le survol en
hélicoptère du volcan est proposé pour
mille francs la demie
c'était aujourd'hui en france la journée
nationale de l'audition chez tous les
médecins spécialistes aux airelles
partenaires de cette opération pouvait
consulter gratuitement
on estime dans notre pays et environ 7
millions le nombre de femmes et d'hommes
qui entendent mal sans toujours s'en
rendre vraiment compte d'ailleurs car
très peu d'entre eux d'entre nous pardon
se soucient avant que le ne s'en
soucient avant que le problème ne soit
devenu déjà très sérieux trop au sérieux
ses fans gays et christian ude si au
lieu d'entendre ça vous entendez il est
temps d'aller faire tester votre
audition chez un spécialiste
et ça tombe bien aujourd'hui la
consultation était gratuite comme
paulette 7 millions de français
souffrent de problèmes d'audition qui
peuvent être gênants au quotidien et
puis le téléphone parce que j'ai un
téléphone est très saine et j'avais un
tapage
pourquoi devient ton sous l'âge bien sûr
comme les yeux les oreilles vieillissent
des 30 ou 40 ans mais le système auditif
peut être usé prématurément par une
surexposition bruit donc qu'on appelle
la cochlée qui la terminaison nerveuse
1e auditifs qui contient des millions de
cellules sensorielles qui lors d'une
agression du vieillissement naturel de
l'oreille se détruisent et donc on perd
un certain nombre ces cellules
sensorielles
ce type d'ambiance pendant plusieurs
heures et celle aux risques de lésions
irréversibles de l'oreille la perte
d'audition n'est pas immédiate mais se
manifestera prématurément seule solution
la prothèse auditive à mettre dans
l'oreille toujours plus petites elles
sont également plus efficace grâce à
l'arrivée des techniques numériques
on n'a plus besoin de réglages de volume
parce que le niveau de volumes s'adapte
en permanence à ce qu'il perçoit ces
appareils permettent de retrouver
jusqu'à 30% de l'audition seul problème
ils sont mal remboursés par la sécurité
sociale
à peine 1300 francs pour un coût total
de dix mille francs
peut-être le prix à payer pour retrouver
le plaisir d'avoir des oreilles en or
les élections régionales avec une des
dernières grandes réunions publiques de
l'opposition ce soir au zénith à paris
pour tenter de mobiliser l'électorat de
droite carole comment oui la droite veut
encore y croire en dépit des derniers
sondages publiés qui était favorable à
la gauche
dernier grand meeting de campagne dans
une région symbolique l'île de france
détenu depuis 20 ans par le rpr
depuis maintenant trois mois ils doivent
balladur y mène une campagne active pour
tenter de conserver la plus importante
région de france il sera soutenu ce soir
par le président du rpr philippe séguin
et le président de l'udf françois
léotard sous le signe de l'union les
chefs de l'opposition adresseront dans
quelques minutes un nouveau message aux
électeurs de droite les électeurs de
droite encore déstabilisé par la sévère
défaite de juin dernier et dont on
craint au rpr canal hier qu'il ne se
réfugie dimanche dans l'abstention
voilà de paris à marseille pour
retrouver monsieur robert hue qui va
participer ce soir un grand meeting en
tant que secrétaire national du parti
communiste monsieur bonsoir bonsoir bien
en tout à l'heure nous avons évoqué la
violence urbaine vous êtes vous-même
premier magistrat maire d'une ville de
la région parisienne est ce que vous
êtes confrontés avec le problème est est
ce que le parti communiste à une
solution dans don d'un délai assez
rapprochées pour traiter ce type de
problème écoutez la violence par un
niveau naturellement que l'on vient de
l'entendre sur vos antennes à travers
les s'est passé hier et avant-hier mais
il est bien évident que la violence
existe partout ce qui vient de se passer
la violence en général a toujours un
caractère insupportable mais là quand il
s'agit de jeunes d'un jeune qui en a il
y a quelque chose de da c'est terrifiant
et je crois que dans ce domaine nous
avons qui peut dire qu'il a une solution
miracle il y à la violence de ce jeune
mais il ya la violence qui est faite à
la jeunesse et à cette crise sociale qui
pèse terriblement mais en même temps je
crois que il y a
dans la réaction des jeunes eux mêmes de
leurs parents deux des responsables sur
le terrain des potentiels nous avons vu
la réaction de ces jeunes tout à l'heure
je descends près sur votre antenne et je
crois qu'il faut s'appuyer sur ces
potentiels il y a naturellement des
moyens à mettre en oeuvre
je crois que on ne peut pas accepter il
faut prendre toutes les dispositions de
sécurité nécessaires on ne peut pas
accepter ce que cette circulation des
armes qui vient et qui est parallèle à
parfois la circulation de la drogue
il faut vraiment prendre des
dispositions et je crois que de ce point
de vue et il y a les moyens dégagés il y
à aussi ce travail très important de
solidarité a tissé sur le terrain je je
crois beaucoup à cette à cette
intervention à ses relations humaines a
ratissé revers eu là vous êtes
entièrement d'accord avec la politique
que mène actuellement le gouvernement
notamment le chevènement sur d'autres
sujets pendant cette campagne vous avez
poussé et les feux sur des sujets de
désaccord de même comme je rappelle le
rô le mouvement des chômeurs vous y
participez vous a même lancé l'idée d'un
moratoire pour geler tous les
licenciements dans les entreprises et le
gouvernement là n'est pas du tout
d'accord ça fait quand même beaucoup de
sujets de désaccord pour une majorité
plurielle on est dans la majorité
plurielle on est déjà dans la division
non absolument pas je suis satisfait des
neuf mois de 2 du gouvernement conduit
par les religieuses pain et des mesures
qui ont été prises d'ailleurs les
communistes participent aux mesures
prises que ce soit l'emploi le plan quoi
jeunes les 35 heures les toute une série
de dispositions
il reste que d'être dans la majorité
plurielle et bien ne gomme pas des
différences je crois que c'est important
que on y lit est d'exprimer des choix
par exemple vous évoquez le mouvement
des chômeurs c'est vrai que le parti
communiste a été au coeur de ce
mouvement et met son son rapport avec
l'action gouvernementale il est
davantage celui d'un trait d'union entre
ce mouvement social important qu'il faut
prendre en compte et le gouvernement
lui-même vous évoquez le moratoire que
j'ai proposé il ne s'agit pas du tout
d'un sujet de désaccord au contraire
d'ailleurs le gouvernement n'a pas pris
position sur cette proposition
qu'est ce que je dis je viens quand même
dit que ce n'était pas envisageable
oui mais je j'en parlerai avec martine
aubry après vie mais bon peut-être avant
mais elle n'est pas là ce soir sinon je
lui en aurait parlé le fond c'est quoi
c'est que nous faisons beaucoup
d'efforts voyez vous pour créer des
emplois des emplois jeunes et pas
seulement en direction des jeunes ou
pour que vraiment l'emploi soit la clé
de notre notre démarche et en même temps
qu'est ce que je vois je vois qu'il y a
des plans sociaux avec des milliers de
licenciements d'annoncer chez renault
chez peugeot
jeudi avant avant que au ccc en pousser
ces licenciements éventuels annuler en
quelque sorte
l'effort qui est fait par lé
gouvernement il convient de prendre des
décisions à moratoire visant à regarder
si par tous les efforts sont faits pour
pouvoir effectivement intégré l'idée des
35 heures développer les dispositions
qui sont prises à skier avant les
charges financières dans l'entreprise à
regarder autant d'éléments qui éviterait
et bien qu'il y ait des des suppressions
de postes supplémentaires
c'est ça va tout à fait dans le sens de
l'effort qui est fait par le
gouvernement en faveur de l'emploi
on verrait chevaux merci bon meeting
donc ce soir et rendez vous dimanche
l'actualité internationale maintenant
aux manifestations continuent au kosovo
un envoyé spécial des états unis est
pourtant arrivé pour discuter avec les
représentants de la majorité albanaise
malgré les risques d'un embargo
international le gouvernement serbe de
son côté refuse toute idée d' ingérence
extérieure dans ce qu'il considère comme
une affaire purement interne à la séance
à santiago du chili aujourd'hui une page
de l'histoire du pays et s'est tournée
avec le départ du général pinochet 82
ans qui quitte avec les honneurs ses
fonctions de commandant de l'armée de
terre pour un poste de sénateur à vie
l'ancien dictateur a décidé lui-même de
sa femme carrière commencée par un coup
d'état en 1973 jérôme b les honneurs
militaires pour l'ancien dictateur
augusto pinochet il compte aujourd'hui
sa retraite
remettant son bâton de commandante en
chef au président frey l'armée chilienne
n'a pas peur de son image et son
commandant 120 avec le sentiment de la
mission accomplie durant ses 65 ans
j'ai marché sur le chantier du devoir et
de la discipline cérémonie guère troublé
par les manifestations des militants de
gauche et des familles des victimes
ils veulent rappeler qu'ici même dans ce
palais présidentiel de la moneda
disparaissait il y à un quart de siècle
le président de gauche salvador allende
qui mit fin à ses jours après avoir
lancé un dernier message à la radio
dans ce grand stade de santiago on
torture on exécute la dictature a pour
objectif principal d'éliminer le
communisme chinois
des milliers de militants de gauche et
de syndicalistes disparaissent en 88
inochi accepte pourtant sa défaite lors
d'un plébiscité il rend son écharpe en
90 malgré les procès en cours pour
rendre justice aux familles des disparus
le vieux soldat semble assuré d'une
retraite dorée
demain il sera nommé sénateur à vie et
surtout il a obtenu le titre de
commandant en chef émérite distinction
rare qui en fait un personnage quasi
intouchable il paraît que nous avons
tous avoir du monde au moins cette
saisie en tout cas le président
américain bill clinton lui en un qui lui
ressemble trait pour trait il a même la
même voix ils s'appellent tim waters et
ce métier de président bis c'est bien
lui rapporte quand même pas mal d'argent
6 millions de francs pour l'année
dernière washington philip chiasson
peut-on croire en une tonne demande ce
panneau pas sur l'amérique est le pays
du plein emploi est aussi celui des
petits boulots
le plus inattendu est certainement celui
de président à temps partiel tim waters
est passé sans transition du métier de
vendeur en immobilier à tampa en floride
à celui de président c'était en 1992
l'activité est certes l'unité dans le
temps qu'à une pun le vrai finira son
mandat en l'an 2000 team en fera autant
non seulement il n'y ressemble plus
qu'un frère mais il limite à la
perfection
cherchez l'erreur
c'est vrai que ça surprend on se demande
ce qu'il fait là en plein scandale et m
avez vous déjà rencontré le président
est devenu célèbre par ressemblance ils
jouent le jeu
afin d'être un président présentable
chaque détail compte lui est un vrai pro
prêt à toute éventualité même à une
rencontre impossible avec i la ruse et
monica un rêve de presse du coeur un
cliché sosie sur le vif les apparences
sont sauves
car tout finit par des baisers retour en
france il y à des modes qui deviennent
de véritables phénomènes de société mais
aussi de très très bonnes affaires
commerciales les fabricants de baskets
chaussures de sport en tout genre sont
en train tout doucement de détrôner les
classiques chaussures en cuir c'est
notre enquête de ce soir à l'occasion de
salons de la chaussure qui vient de se
tenir à paris reportage sophie mais elle
jean-pierre pasteur nike l'auto new
balance freebox jordan une centaine de
paires à fixer dans vingt mètres carrés
pour une collection de mordus comme il
en existe peu en france
j'ai réuni vingt ans s'est laissé happer
par le virus tout a commencé il ya dix
ans dans la cour de récré avoir le
dernier modèle super cool pour frimer
devant les copains c'est cuit il traque
les collecteurs d'un modèle très
actuelle les pommes curie qu'on trouve
en noir aujourd'hui a été réédité pour
l'indépendance d'hong kong
alors ça ce sont des lotos super
brooklyn ça dans le nom nike air foot
skype avec une nouvelle technologie avec
les lacets sur les côtés comme on peut
voir son plaisir connaître l'histoire de
chacun de ces trésors une documentation
extrêmement bien fourni qu'il collecte
auprès des fabricants sur internet
rue tiquetonne avait pas du sentier
parisien nous sommes chez culte la
boutique de référence pour le petit
cercle de collectionneurs les modèles
les plus cotés air jordan air pegasus
pomme furie de la première génération
bâle 6 7 10 mille francs voire plus les
puristes se moque bien de savoir si
elles sont à la bonne pointure pour les
collectionneurs remous japon et prennent
soin de chercheurs ou trop grande entre
piétons avec les pieds rien faire c'est
la tortière pour du fétichisme si les
extrémistes ne sont pas encore légion en
france les simples adeptes se comptent
par millions la basket sport de plus en
plus à la ville huit paires sur dix ne
foulerons jamais les stades
c'est vraiment un phénomène généralisé
au monde entier sa des chiffres énormes
c'est c'est vraiment le phénomène je
crois le plus frappant en matière de
mode de la fin du siècle
les gamins les plus accomplis entre 14
et 18 ans et dépensent des sommes
colossales pour ses chaussures voulait
de moi c'est que je me suis rassis 107
s'emballe on reçoit les parents à rose
entre lisieux et soit fois on sait on
sait pas d'où ça vient lancer sans
savoir donc
- mais par un 10 qui coûte cher c'est ce
qui est mieux que ce que ce qui coûte
pas cher à mon ami c'est à moi de mai ce
qui coûte un peu cher sa bonne qualité
la paire la plus branchée du moment
l'air max 95 argent rupture de stock
dans toute la france pour un modèle qui
vaut tout de même 900 enfants
les fans vont jusqu'à londres pour la
trouver
autre mode les couleurs flashent des new
balance la marque commence même à
sérieusement concurrencer le leader nike
pour faire partie du top ten les
fabricants se décarcasser sort que de
nouvelles références angers continue
2000 par an chez nike et si cela ne
suffisait pas le géant américain vient
d'annoncer des profits à la baisse et
les coupes d'effectifs
preuve que les adolescents sont
décidément les plus capricieux les
consommateurs quelques 2000 viticulteurs
ont manifesté aujourd'hui à bagnols sur
cèze dans le gard ils entendaient
protester contre un projet de
laboratoire souterrain de stockage de
déchets radioactifs politique hutter de
la drôme craignent que la présence d'un
tel laboratoire sur leur territoire ne
porte préjudice à la commercialisation
de leurs produits de leurs vins
peut-on concilier réserve naturelle et
confort des touristes c'est la question
posée en camargue où certains hôteliers
estime que la présence de moustiques en
masse nuit gravement à l'essor du
tourisme local le problème c'est que
dans une région préservée tout
traitement radical est interdit sauf à
mettre gravement en cause l'équilibré
écologique reportage jacques cardoze
jean françois forget début mars les
ragondins sont plus nombreux que les
moustiques
mais lorsque la chaleur et l'humidité
s'annonce la chaîne vient bien de ces
insectes assoiffés véritable plaie des
camarguais et certains d'entre eux
décident de mener bataille c'est le cas
d'albert l'escaut ce responsable d'un
centre de vacances est également à la
tête d'une association qui réclame une
campagne globale de démoustication
il faut savoir que deux partout où les
moustiques et chacun fait n'importe quoi
à l'intérieur de sa propriété privée je
crois que si c'est ça des fois dans la
camargue accepte c'est pas une bonne
solution pour éviter les actions
sauvages comme ici une entente
intersyndicale étudie actuellement la
nocivité des produits employés l'un
d'entre eux pourrait satisfaire aussi
bien les défenseurs de la nature que les
professionnels du tourisme mais à
certaines conditions
ses utilisations en vraie grandeur de
notre nombre de produits on en est pour
résultat qu'on ait effectivement détruit
les moustiques bon mais personne ne peut
dire ce que l'on a détruit avec cette
destruction
donc nous autres parcs cela nous disons
nous voulons veiller à voir mais il faut
d'abord expérimenté pas question de
faire n'importe quoi en l'absence
d'études sérieuses et au détriment de la
faune et la flore car les dangers sont
réels pour les pensionnaires de ces
marécages les moustiques ont toujours
existé entre marg je ne cache pas que
c'est vrai c'est pas un agrément d'avoir
des moustiques le soir mais nous avons
un pays qui malheureusement ou
heureusement demande des moustiques pour
la chaîne aliments pose la
démoustication pourrait faire sourire
mais les chiffres démontrent à quel
point la question est sérieuse
ici la fréquentation des campings est en
baisse constante
la femme est décidément l'égal de
l'homme après l' aventure de gérard
d'aboville traversant l'atlantique à la
rame c'est une jeune française peggy
bouchet qui a décidé de faire la même
chose et qui a quitté les îles canaries
direction les antilles à 24 ans elle
espère bien parcourir les cinq mille
kilomètres jusqu'aux antilles donc en
trois ou quatre mois
c'est à voir selon temps et selon mes
forces
la mode du prêt à porter automne hiver
prochain aujourd'hui dior mais aussi le
belge dries van noten et l'éternel yves
saint laurent une confrontation entre le
spectaculaire et un style de plus en
plus épuré pour yves saint laurent
sophie mais elle hervé pauthe
on reprochait à galliano de s'embourber
dans un style passéiste le voilà qui
fait volte face et s'engage dans une
note des roues doudoune anorak capuche
pour des rappeuses endimanchés à la
recherche de sensations fortes les
couleurs acidulées comme grincer des
dents mais est ce vraiment suffisant
pour faire moderne
les clients de dior risque fort d'être
déboussolés
pourquoi un peu trop le compère anglais
qui ressort là il faut maigrir mais
l'important c'est de faire du spectacle
la maison gucci chaque saison des
millions pour ses présentations son
poulain est dopée aux hormones difficile
de surenchérir
quand on défile le même jour best de
cosaques et bottes cavalières pour
échauffer des bohémiennes égaré sur des
chemins de traverse
dries van noten s'est laissé emporter
dans un nouveau voyage je veux en
bataille de [ __ ] et maquillage
yéménite dont les courbes s'entrelacer
se délient au rythme des motifs et des
superpositions de cette mode nomade
pas question de se mesurer au reste de
la meute pour yves saint laurent qui a
pris l'habitude de se retrancher dans
ses salons de l'avenue marceau la
quintessence de la féminité même en
smoking surtout en smoking tout juste
une trentaine de modèles ses préférés et
la rencontre d'un style abouti jusqu'au
bout des ongles
une élégance toute simple sans
fioritures qui se passe même du moindre
souffle de musique le cinéma cette
semaine avec un nouveau clint eastwood
sans qu'une 10 août puisque la star
américaine n'assure que la réalisation
du film intitulé minuit dans le jardin
du bien et du mal une incursion étrange
dans l'intimité d'une ville du sud des
états unis
savannah le tout sur fond d' enquêtes
policières pascal deschamps c'est loin
des plaines du far west où des rues
glauque des métropoles américaines que
clint eastwood a posé sa caméra à
savannah dans une de ces vieilles villes
du sud dont le passé à fleurs à chaque
coin de rue
c'est là que débarque et nous avec un
journaliste new yorkaise venue faire le
portrait du richissime antiquaires jim
williams mais dès le lendemain dit
williams est accusé du meurtre de son
petit ami au premier abord le 21e opus
de clint eastwood serait donc une
enquête policière
en apparence seulement car le
réalisateur s'amuse à nous balader au
sein d'une faune qui ne ressemble à
aucune autre et dont l'un d'eux lance le
dispute à l'extravagance gerland tu
oublies ton entre oui je sais j'ai passé
trois jours ici c'est juste des coups de
feu mais donne un peu de temps d'accord
cette ville est fantastique et autant en
emporte le vent sous l'escalier oui je
sais que tu es mon agent écoutons mal
ils promènent des animaux imaginaires
carland au bout d'une laisse tu
comprends ils seront tous lourdement
armés et son new york a coûté sinistre
je te rappelle c'est vrai je m'amuse
parfois à dire que j'ai la nostalgie de
l'odeur du désert et des grands espaces
de l'ouest mais j'adore ce que je fais
aujourd'hui
ce film ne ressemble à aucun de ceux que
j'ai fait avant et cet endroit a rien de
ce que je sais montrer
derrière les apparences farfelu se cache
une communauté jalouse de sa liberté et
derrière le polar un plaidoyer pour la
tolérance
je n'ai rien contre les films effets
spéciaux tout ce que je dis c'est qu'il
est bon parfois de s'attaquer à des
sujets qui intéressent les plus de 25
ans on veut tourner pas moniste world
has often clint eastwood réalise depuis
toujours défini donne pour nous montre l
amérique dans laquelle ils aimeraient
vivre
ne vous fiez pas aux apparences semble
donc dire qu'ils discutent dans ce film
derrière le regard bleu acier de
l'ancien pistolero se cache un
réalisateur qui film après film dénonce
la violence et dévoile les ambiguïtés de
l'âme humaine
voilà ce journal est terminée je vous
rappelle le premier titre de l'actualité
de ce mardi brouillard et vitesse à
l'origine d'un carambolage manceau sur
l'autoroute près de thionville
une centaine de voitures en cause le
bilan 53 blessés dont huit dans un état
jugé très sérieux
dans quelques instants la météo de
sophie davant qui nous allons des
risques de chutes de neige sur la région
parisienne et dans l'est
cette nuit et demain matin attention
donc 20h50 ma femme quitte un film
français avec thierry lhermitte et
miou-miou 7h50 demain dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra marie
christine blandin présidente écologiste
ou la région nord pas de calais puis 13
heures toujours les régionales en direct
de strasbourg avec patrick chêne et
antoine cormery a pas voilà je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
chaîne bonsoir à tous